what if yurichi had become a demon
instead of kokushibo this could change
everything right but to what extent in
this video we'll be looking at how
things would have played out if yurichi
did an anakin skywalker and got
corrupted by the dark side act one in
this version of the story yurichi would
be egotistical and selfish he would hate
humans because they don't show enough
appreciation towards demon slayers and
most of them don't even know they exist
yorishi would believe that they are
oblivious and ungrateful and therefore
don't deserve saving he would also seek
to become stronger and stronger which
would eventually lead him to face muzon
same as in the original story your issue
would battle muzon and eventually defeat
him with his 13th form at this point
muzon screams in despair as he finally
begins to come to terms with how
powerless and weak he is before a mere
human a prodigy born with the demon
slayer mark transparent world and the
selfless state before musan can look up
gurichi is already standing right next
to him muzon tries to split up into
pieces and escape but he has no strength
left to do so he grovels before yurichi
and pleads for his life he begs the
human to spare him and tries to convince
him to switch sides you don't have to
kill me
what's the point why do you continue to
defend those poor humans
who do not even know that you exist
while saying this muzan thinks of a way
to escape but he fearfully decides
against it knowing it will end in
futility and seal his fate with a quick
death so he continues talking the humans
have failed you
you go out
every day to save them and yet they show
you no gratitude even those who know of
your existence
are only envious
and jealous of you
they only want to see you fail muzon
pleads with him to switch sides offering
him immortality in place of his fragile
human life a selfish side of yurichi
that we haven't seen before starts to
emerge he laughs and mocks muzon while
telling him of how he hates humans and
only kills demons for the sake of
getting stronger at last he accepts his
offer on a condition that he can kill
anyone who angers him and that he is
free to do whatever he likes
irrespective of muzon's orders muzon
gives him his blood and the demonic
yorishi is born with his exceptional
skills and strength yorishi easily
becomes the upper moon one and soon
takes the position as muzon's right hand
man with your reaching now out of the
demon slayer core his elder twin brother
michikatsu is now the strongest demon
slayer in this era and he would go on to
defeat many strong demons mijikatsu will
no longer envy his brother as he did in
the original story deeming him pathetic
for falling to the dark side he will
eventually start a family and have kids
teaching them the moon breathing while
compelling them to pass it on to the
future generations act 2 due to
yurichi's decision to become a demon a
lot of things are different this time
around so here's a little backstory of
the current world the demon slayer core
specifically the hashiras are much
stronger than in the original story
unlike the manga where the upper moons
haven't been changed for over a century
in this world the 12 kizuki have seen
several changes due to the incredibly
strong pillars there are two insanely
strong moon breathing users in the ranks
of the hashira now the twin brothers
muichiro and yurichiro let us explain
this part for a bit as you all know
muichiro is a descendant of tsugikuni
bloodline and since michikatsu taught
moonbreathing to his descendants in this
world he would possess the moon
breathing instead of missed breathing
his brother yuichuro would also be alive
in this version of the story as he would
be strong enough to defend himself from
demons that killed him in the original
version this time around the information
about demon slayer marks and other
abilities would be passed down
accurately throughout the generations
which led to the core being much
stronger than before comodo family would
never learn the sun breathing form
yurishi and therefore tanjuro would live
comfortably in the mountains as a normal
human oblivious of the constant wars
between the slayers and demons don't
worry about nezuko guys i wouldn't
provoke the wrath of the fandom by
killing her off she also lives with
tantro and the rest of their family in
the mountains obviously muzan has seen
how strong the hashiris have become and
how his demons pale in comparison
however he is not troubled by it since
he has an ace up his sleeve the upper
moon won yurichi yurichi didn't really
show himself much throughout the years
only appearing a few times since he
became a demon however whenever he does
appear he kills every demon slayer and
ashira in his vicinity no one ever
survived the encounter with him and
therefore the demon slayer core is
completely unaware of his true power
they don't even know what he looks like
due to hishira becoming stronger and
stronger with each generation muzon
realizes that there is no point in
waiting anymore and therefore starts
preparing his final attack on the demon
slayer core planning to finish them all
in one final battle he summons all upper
moons including yurichi commanding them
to prepare as the final battle begins
tonight the time has come my demons
tonight we'll finally destroy these
pathetic humans and show them what the
real power looks like
act three the final battle muzon storms
the ubu yashiki mansion like he did in
the manga forcing kagaya to make a
self-sacrifice which gives tomayo the
chance to poison the demon king gyome
arrives first he decapitates muzon's
head and as the head regenerates the
other hashiras arrive learning of
kagaya's death moichiro is visibly
enraged and he says to muzon you will
die for this he launches an attack moon
breathing first form dark moon evening
palace muzon is able to deflect most of
the crescent moons coming his way but
few of them still managed to slash and
injure him as all the other hashiras
gather around muzon trying to attack him
with their techniques muzon lets out a
hideous laugh as doors begin to open and
all of the hashiras get transported into
the infinity castle the whole place is
crawling with demons albeit weak ones
and the hashers easily get rid of them
due to being injected with poison muzon
is regenerating in his cocoon and sends
all of the upper moons to stall them in
the meantime as the hashira has finished
defeating all lower ranked demons and
branch into other rooms of the castle
they finally encounter the upper moons
muichiro's senses are troubled as the
stench of blood is very heavy on his
nose he runs towards the direction of
the smell and encounters a room filled
with corpses while someone with black
hair is seated at the far end of the
room the man stands up revealing two
devilish horns on his head and he speaks
in a monstrous voice who are you why did
you enter my room still facing the other
side yurichi doesn't look at yurichiro
rather he is disgusted that someone has
entered his lair without permission he
launches a sunflower thrust attack that
is deflected by giu who has now arrived
at the scene along with yurichiro and
gyome everyone realizes that it is the
legendary urichi that is standing in
front of them and the four demon slayers
prepared to face the biggest challenge
of their lives
during this time the other hashiris all
fight against the other five upper moons
in an attempt to kill muzon while he is
weakened by the drug back to the big
fight the four hashiris all take turns
launching attacks at yurichi which he
easily evades yomma gets yurichi trapped
in a corner while giul slashes him with
the water-breathing fifth form blessed
reign after the drought he was sure his
attack injured yurichi but the demon
laughs mockingly saying ha i'm amazed
you thought that will have an effect on
me yorishi goes on and continues saying
how he is unimpressed with their skills
i thought this was the golden age of the
hashira but you all surrounded me like
puppies and yet you can do no damage to
me this fight is a waste of my time you
reach these countenance changes
immediately showing that he wants to end
the fight as soon as possible but he
gets under heavy attack from a moon
breathing combo by the twins that sends
him flying through the wall as he gets
up he is immediately kicked by gilmay
and the stone hashira follows through
with fourth form volcanic rock rapid
conquest the two-pronged attack makes
contact with yurichi and he can be seen
bleeding from his stomach however to the
horror of all the demon slayers his
injuries heal in an instant he tears off
the kimono he is wearing and uses it to
clean the blood on his skin he calmly
states not bad but now it's my turn
yurishi unleashes sun breathing burning
bones summer sun a large circular slash
that attacks all four demon slayers at
once uitrud and morichiro were able to
react in time and dodge the attack while
gyome and giu were hit and effectively
paralyzed by the attack urichi's blood
demon art makes humans or demons who are
hit by any of his attacks unable to move
for a short period of time the stronger
the attack the longer that period is
nurichi congratulate the twins on how
strong they have become descendants of
my pathetic brother you share my blood
and my strengths don't be stupid
thinking you can defeat me here
join me so you can become even stronger
and live forever the brothers vehemently
reject him with muichiro saying the once
great yurichi you've fallen even deeper
into the darkness than i imagined we
will never stoop down your level the
brothers close their eyes and a bright
light begins to emanate from their
bodies yurichi cautions them saying that
this attack is producing way more energy
than their bodies can handle and it will
certainly lead to their deaths yuichiro
replies you are right we will surely die
once we perform this attack but if
that's what it takes to stop you we
don't mind
continues by stating the tsujikuni clan
knew no single individual can ever hope
to defeat you so they came up with a
dual attack that must be performed by
two people in perfect sink however
throughout the years there were never
two individuals strong enough to perform
it correctly everyone who has ever tried
it has either died or been grievously
injured by the attack's energy since you
and michikatsu we are the first twins
born into the clan in over 500 years we
knew this moment will come and we
prepared hard for it this is where you
die riichi at first yorishi laughs
asking them if they really think they
can defeat the great yorichi however as
the energy the brothers produce becomes
more and more powerful yurichi starts to
show signs of worry he is surprised that
their strength is rising far beyond the
levels he expected he thinks to himself
that he must attack the brothers before
they unleash this attack as he is not
willing to risk getting hit by it urichi
rushes towards the two demon slayers in
order to attack them before they fully
prepare however giulio and gyomay appear
in his path determined to keep him away
from them nurici quickly attacks them
slashing both demon slayers with his
sword nonetheless skiu and gyome stand
up again they both drop their weapons
and run towards dorichi clutching him
with her arms ritchie tries to break
free but their grip is too strong he
yells at them asking if they are insane
saying that if they don't let him go
they will all die before yurichi can say
anything else the two boys finish their
preparation giyu and gilma yell at them
not to hesitate and attack while they
are still holding him knowing that they
will die in the process the brothers
tear up thanking their fellow demon
slayers for their sacrifice and finally
unleash their attack moon breathing
final form solar eclipse
the attack is launched and everything
goes white with the infinity castle
getting destroyed as the dust clears
guillaume and giu are on the ground dead
muichiro and his brother are also on the
ground both barely breathing they
briefly look at each other and smile
thankful to their clan for entrusting
them with this technique we actually
managed to do it we defeated him
yeah
i just hope the others will manage to
defeat musan without us not far from
them yoricci is disintegrating with his
last breath he mumbles to himself this
was not meant
to happen
how did i lose
how
could i lose
dead the remaining hashires attack a
weak and injured muzon who was forced
out of his cocoon and is still hindered
by tamayo's poison they managed to stall
him until dawn and the demon king is
finally defeated by the sun bringing an
end to the era of demons click on this
video where we explained what would
happen if rangoku accepted akasa's offer
to become a demon